[Music]
everyone seems to be embracing their
natural beauty these days
even Disney Princesses with the help of
photo editing software our favorite
Disney Princesses have received a bit of
a makeover their makeup has been
digitally removed and these photos of
them and all their natural glory will
absolutely amaze you if you're new to
our Channel please subscribe and give
this video a big thumbs up today we'll
be showing you ten photos of Disney
Princesses without makeup just wait
until you see what Cinderella looks like
when she goes all natural she's just as
beautiful as ever
Elsa you've probably seen this image of
Elsa all glammed up a hundred times in
this picture the frozen character wears
pink and purple eyeshadow a coat of
mascara on her eyelashes dark eyeliner
pink lipstick and a bit of peach blush
on her cheeks we absolutely love the way
Disney animators designed her and the
colors they use blend perfectly together
to bring out her icy blue eyes and her
platinum blonde hair but check out Elsa
as she rocks a more natural look her
eyeshadow has been completely wiped away
and her long full and voluminous
eyelashes aren't as noticeable as before
without the heavy eyeliner on her
appearance is much softer and youthful
even without the blush on her cheeks and
a lipstick on her lips she still has a
beautiful and healthy glow to her skin
she definitely looks different but in a
good way of course her natural beauty
shines through and we think she looks as
gorgeous as ever are you shocked by
Elsa's natural look as much as we are
Jasmine Princess Jasmine doesn't wear as
much makeup as some of the other Disney
Princesses but she's still a fan of
beauty products her dark hair and
features are even more noticeable with
her black eyeliner that wings out at the
corners of her eyes her red lipstick
also gives her a nice and full palette
now take a look at this image of the
Aladdin character going all natural are
you as shocked as we are we can't take
our eyes off of her in this photo
jasmine looks absolutely beautiful some
people have to deal with a few blemishes
when they wash their face at the end of
the day but not Jasmine her skin looks
as
and blemish free as ever we wouldn't be
surprised if the princess never suffered
from an acne breakout in her entire life
this photo of Jazmin without products on
her face just proves that she's the
definition of flawless do you think
Princess Jasmine looks better with or
without makeup on Snow White one of the
most dramatic transformations comes from
none other than Snow White if you look
at the images from the 1938 movie you
can definitely tell the princess has a
thing for getting all dolled up in this
photo
Snow White can be seen with pencil thin
eyebrows that have been filled in a bit
of light purple eyeshadow on her lids
red blush on her cheeks and some red
lipstick on her lips she looks like she
could be on the cover of a Glamour
magazine doesn't she now take a look at
this photo
of so white without the rosy blush her
cheeks are less defined but the
roundness of her face makes her look
absolutely adorable don't you think she
looks so much younger and more youthful
her brown eyes stand out even more than
before and even when she's not wearing
her signature red lipstick her lips
naturally have a beautiful pink
undertone just looking at Snow White's
all-natural look makes us wish Disney
had included more scenes of the princess
with her beautiful bare face on full
display
Tiana in the film The Princess and the
Frog
Tiana switches up her outfits many times
but her makeup pretty much stays the
same to complement her yellow outfit she
wears to work at the diner the princess
has a bit of purple shadow on her lids
black eyeliner on her top lash line a
little bit of blush on the apples of her
cheeks and deep breath lipstick on her
lips now are you ready to see what the
princess would look like without any
makeup on well here she is if Tiana had
decided to show up to work with a bare
face we're sure no one would have even
noticed she looks even more beautiful
when she goes all natural her light
brown eyes are much more prominent and
striking and her lips still have a
natural shade of color that really
brings out the gold undertones in her
skin
do you prefer to see Princess Tiana with
or without makeup on make sure to let us
know down below in the comment section
and the most are
no reply will get penned to our channel
Mulan even Mulan is wearing makeup the
Disney Princesses makeup application is
very light and natural animators worked
very hard to keep her look nice and
simple in this photo she wears a bit of
eyeliner on her top lash line and it
wings out towards the outer corners of
her eyes then she has a dusting of pink
blush on the highest part of her
cheekbones and a swipe of lipstick on
her lips are you ready to see the bare
face version of this Disney Princess
check her out now
we love that you can see a few of the
imperfections on her skin around her
eyes
it makes her bare face look much more
realistic don't you think
even though Lou LAN is a stunner with
makeup on we love the way she looks in
this edited photo her eyeliner blush and
lipstick are long gone instead she's
sporting a bare face and she still looks
like a million bucks seen Mulan without
any added colors on her face has
convinced us that she is indeed a
natural beauty don't you agree Merida
when it was announced Merida would be
joining the Disney Princess lineup this
official photo of the brave character
was released you can tell that animators
got her all dolled up for her big reveal
in the photo Merida has mascara and
eyeliner on orange lipstick on her lips
and a hint of pink blush on her cheeks
the colors all work together perfectly
to really bring out her beautiful red
hair and her piercing blue eyes this
next photo is how many people know and
love the Disney Princess when Merida's
wandering around the kingdom with her
bow and arrow by her side she goes for a
makeup free look her eyes appear to be
much whiter and they even look more
vivid when she is not wearing eye makeup
and without the blush on her cheeks the
natural rosiness in her skin is able to
peek through we can even get a glimpse
of the tiny freckles on her cheeks and
nose with her smooth and perfect skin we
understand why Merida is most often seen
going makeup free skin this beautiful
deserves to be seen at all times
Pocahontas Pocahontas spends most of her
free time roaming around the great
outdoors and
becoming one with nature but that
doesn't mean the Disney princess always
embraces a more natural look images of
the Disney character show her with
eyeliner lining her top and bottom lash
lines and a bit of beautiful light brown
lipstick on her lips we think Pocahontas
is stunning in her original form but
wait until you see what she looks like
when it all comes off just take a look
at this gorgeous picture of her she
looks absolutely amazing and her skin is
so clear it actually looks like it's
glowing without her black eyeliner on
Pocahontas looks a lot younger and more
vibrant don't you agree
and check out her lips when she's not
wearing her favorite lipstick her lips
have a natural orange shade to them we
would love to receive some pointers from
Pocahontas on how she keeps her skin
looking so beautiful do you love her
makeup free look just as much as we do
make sure to leave your reply down below
in the comment section Cinderella a blog
that goes by the name pish-posh design
was inspired by other images of Disney
Princesses without makeup to join in on
the movement on their quest to encourage
women to embrace their natural beauty
they decided to give the princesses a
makeover of their own with the use of
editing software they were able to
completely alter a few of their images
in the blink of an eye the princess's
makeup was removed and their natural
looks were put on display one of the
princesses who received an all natural
makeover is Cinderella
check out this before picture of the
princess you can see that she has
beautiful faust lashes that they are
long and thick she wears pink lipstick
and a tiny hint of peach blush on her
cheeks now it's time to see her after
photo can you believe this is really
Cinderella she looks completely
different doesn't she her false lashes
had been stripped away and without them
you can get lost in her beautiful blue
eyes when she isn't wearing any lipstick
her eyes don't stand out as much but
they still have a lovely shape to them
don't you think we love this make a free
picture of Cinderella and it shows us
that underneath all of the makeup she's
still one of the most beautiful Disney
Princesses ever Arielle just because she
lives her life under the sea
it doesn't mean Ariel
doesn't wear anything to enhance her
beauty she doesn't put on a full face of
products like some of the other
princesses but she does have a hint of
makeup on to bring out her natural
beauty in this photo of the character
from The Little Mermaid you can see that
the eyelashes on the top corners of her
eyes appear to be a bit darker Arielle
is definitely a fan of mascara then she
has a little bit of red lipstick on her
lips to bring out her vibrant red hair
and a tiny bit of foundation on her face
she still looks very natural
and were not really surprised it must be
a pain for her to find a bunch of
waterproof products when Ariel isn't
wearing anything on her skin this is
what she looks like
this altered photo shows what Ariel's
lashes would look like without any
mascara and when she doesn't wear her
favorite red lipstick her lips natural
pink tone is more apparent this photo
also shows a few of the imperfections on
the mermaids face but who needs to wear
makeup when you look as beautiful as she
does we would have loved if Disney
showed Ariel in her natural state more
often throughout the film how about you
Belle there's a reason why Belle is
called a beauty in the film Beauty and
the Beast just look at her in this photo
she has a classic and timeless look that
has been celebrated for years her big
brown eyes are even more breathtaking
when she accentuates them with a bit of
mascara and eyeliner her cheekbones
become more pronounced when she adds a
bit of pink blush and we think her pink
lipstick is the perfect shade how about
you although we can't get enough of
Belle's gorgeous features we love her
all-natural look even more just check
her out in this edited photo the Disney
princess receives a makeover that
consists of wiping the products
completely off her face take a look at
how beautiful she looks now if you
thought her eyes were big before don't
they look even bigger without the
mascara and eyeliner her cheekbones are
still on fleek even if she isn't wearing
any blush and your lips have a natural
and gorgeous colour to them just like
the other princesses on our list Belle's
face is smooth and blemish free which of
these photos of Disney Princesses
without makeup shocked you the most
react in the comments section down below
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up
[Music]